claude il s'appelle claude et s'étale
agences de voyage que je les rencontre
et ils venaient chaque mois cherche un
catalogue et prochaine toujours des
voyages à l'étranger
jusqu'au jour où il m'a proposé d'aller
au bout du monde avec lui
évidemment j'ai accepté il était si
charmant et ils m'amusais tellement et
voilà que je me retrouve dans sa cuisine
à lui préparer des petits plats
alors ça vient ça vient ça vient non ça
ne vient pas et que deux clubs j'en ai
marre j'en ai marre puisque c'est comme
ça moi je reste à la maison
alors qu'est ce que je vais manger moi
maintenant
faire un petit truc un petit truc pour
moi tout seul un truc français pour
changer et dans l'est
ah oui on va jamais dans l'est quand on
prévoir quand on prépare est content
présente dès lé menu des repas et tout
alors qu'il ya plein de trucs très bon
ou alors c'est toujours la choucroute
n'y a pas que ça dans l'est par exemple
en lorraine je pourrais me faire un
p'tit un petit cendres au vin rouge de
toul avec des girolles comme entrée en
matière en matière gastronomique bien
entendu un peu de charcuterie des
ardennes c'est à dire du jambon des
ardennes attention pas trop faim les
tranches de jambon des ardennes pour que
c'est une certaine consistance du pâté
de grive une petite saucisse des
ardennes que l'on peut faire réchauffer
on peut faire cuire carrément et puis ne
pas oublier les petits oignons blancs
les cornichons le beurre un bon pain de
campagne à la rigueur si vous avez
encore un petit creux vous ajoutez une
tourte à la viande et des pâtes et
laurens et pour arroser le tout un petit
gris de toul alors très frais le gris de
toul
en passant par la lorraine
un petit cendres aux vins de tout le
centre c'est un poisson de rivière la
rivière qui passe à toul basse et la
moselle
et c'est là où l'on à pêcher ce poisson
se cendres et comme on va pas mettre
l'eau de la moselle
on va plutôt ajouter un peu de vin de
toul attention du rouge de toul rouge de
toul du poivre du sel les citrons des
échalotes que l'on va chez finement un
coulis thomas du beurre des girolles des
poireaux qui on est et émincé et de la
moelle 2 alors tout d'abord nous allons
préparer ce que l'on appelle un petit
fumet de poisson assez pour donner du
goût
alors pour ça c'est très simple on
prépare une fois une poêle une casserole
ou ceux ci par exemple c'est pour vous
voyez bien et puis on met un petit peu
de beurre simplement pour tapisser le
fond et de manière à ce que le vern ne
prenne pas une odeur parfois s'il reste
un petit peu de vaisselle c'est ce que
c'est alors danser et que ça permet de
se soit plus moelleux juste un petit peu
de ne pas beaucoup hein
elle fonde un petit peu fait revenir
comme ça surtout faut pas que ça
que ça bouffe pas tout ça crépite
rien de tout ça et puis vous versez vous
placez dedans les abats de votre poisson
c'est à dire que vous avez des coupes et
le sandre vous avez fait les filets
comme ça y'a pas beaucoup d'art est
c'est très pratique ce genre de poisson
après voulait présenterez mieux vous les
rangs du couperet et vous avez dix ont
isolé les arrête et entre autres l'art
est principal l'arête centrale
vous avez laissé quand même de la chair
autour vous vous laissez revenir à un
tout petit peu voilà il faut pas que ça
surtout pas que sa crise fait tourner un
peu comme ça ça chauffe très très peu
[Musique]
que ça traîne voilà et puis vous prenez
le rouge de toul très difficile à
trouver mais si vous ne trouvez pas de
rouge de toul
vous prenez un rouge les géants quelque
chose par rapport au corps sais pas et
là vous mettez un demi litre de ce rouge
depuis les sommes recouvrées
pratiquement le poisson est évidemment
ainsi le bourrelet ne lésinons pas sur
la marchandise
le vin bien prendre dans la chair du
poisson et les arêtes vous laisser
revenir un tout petit peu et vous
attendez que ça frémissent ça va ça
commence à frémir doucement c'est
carrément une petite son sens rien du
tout c'est pour donner aux vins que vous
reverserait ensuite sur le poisson est
avec vous mélangerez avec les échalotes
avec tout ça pour lui donner le déjà le
goût du poisson
ne pensez pas trop dessus parce que vous
risqueriez d'être en état d'ébriété
quelque temps avant que votre promises
arrivent et maintenant elle vous prenez
délicatement le poisson ne s'agit pas
y'a pas beaucoup d'arrêts mais il s'agit
pas dans l'eau en maître dans la
préparation
voilà vous placer ça comme ça ils nous
versaient voilà ça passe bien vous
écoutez bien et vous avez maintenant
donc un fumet voilà qui est un très bon
fumée et ce fut mais vous allez le
mettre au chaud par exemple dans votre
four
alors vous avez évidemment préparé
toutes vos petites choses c'est à dire
que vous avez mince et vos poireaux et
vous les avez fait cuire dans un peu
d'eau et un petit peu de de sel est un
peu de beurre attention il faut que les
poireaux soit très vert 1 et très
croquant encore rien à crocs et de la
nouvelle cuisine
donc c'est à peine cuit
et puis également vous avez fait cuire
vos girolles et l'eau qui est des
gorgées de ces girolles le jus des
girolles vous en met deux servis pour
médecins dans la sauce que vous avez
préparer la sauce c'est ce que l'on a
fait tout à l'heure le fumet avec le vin
auquel vous avez ajouté un coulis de
tomate l'eau donc un peu de girolles et
puis la moelle également qui hélas est
moi qui va servir à décorer
vous l'avez enlever cette malle pour
battre votre source pour la prêter un
peu avec du beurre l'a fait remonter
quelque peu voilà et puis ensuite vous
avez coupé
votre sens auquel vous avez laissé la
peau évidemment de d'enlever les
écailles mettons-les sakho c'est bien
meilleur et on le peut tout venir
enlever la peau au moment de servir
et maintenant nous allons faire frire ce
poisson voilà ce qu un petit peu avec
leur maître de jeu mais les triais voilà
contraint
alors pour faire frire ce poisson
espère-t-elle à penser que soient dorés
un tout petit peu je sais pas ça attaque
bien sûr vous passez à sa suite vous
allez mettre maintenant le siphon
les corps
c
le beurre ne doit surtout pas devenir
noir mat en main tout tu peux maintenant
et on va en profiter pour vous pour ce
fameux gr de toul qui a servi à composer
la sauce à base de la sauce jours à
peine c'est un ministre devant le cube
avec les arêtes qui fait le fumet
d'abord même table
c'est le drame des cuisiniers
ils sont tentées sans arrêt parce qu'ils
font à manger et puis par la boisson
aussi alors il faut être très
raisonnable
surtout qu'après c'est pas ton temps tu
ville voilà leur servir de ma garde
ces pratiques
déjà racheté toujours à portée de la
main et les rives doucement pour ne pas
se croiser des femmes
sinon n'est pas poursuivi ne s'arrêtera
pas et il a maintenant voilà nouvelles
ex épouse avant
le gars est maintenant tout est dans le
jeu de la disposition avantages du
poisson c'est très peu de calories
ils vont venir et la sauce l on a bien
sûr dont l'offre est très prudent est-ce
que la moelle risque de se défaire on va
mettre l'autre de l'autre côté et les
deux devant on répartir mieux parce
qu'elles sont plus larges où on et
prendre ensuite les légumes et qui vont
servir également d'éléments de
décoration
alors les girolles elle sent très très
bon et a le droit est très bonne hop
voilà vous pouvez m
un petit peu de là et nous avons notre
cendres aux girolles et au vin rouge de
toul
[Musique]